i would let ben barnes spit in my mouth
and i would use it as mouthwash
i need i need a set of i needed 70 here
oh okay that's better now it's going to
be fine hello i am ben barnes and i am
here with buzzfeed to read my first
tweet i have no idea why
[Music]
as much as i want it ben barnes is not
doing that first tweets video
we all saw his reaction to the calm heda
t thing i know what that was during that
instagram game so i cannot imagine him
reading the word [ __ ] bossy [ __ ] i'm
not cool enough to know what [ __ ] means
out loud i'd pay him a thousand dollars
if he could do it and read everything
fully well autumn you owe me one
thousand of your american dollars
because i just read that out loud
without knowing what [ __ ] means i could
be saying anything it sounds rude but i
don't quite know how to react because i
don't know what i'm saying
someone from buzzfeed has just come in
and told me what messy means and
that's why my face is going red ben
barnes are you free february 14th
because i'm free february 14th and i
would like to hang out with you on
february the 14th when i am free so
please let me know if you're free to
hang out on february the 14th because i
would like to hang out on february the
14th when i am free
that is excellent and very very sweet i
i actually would love to do that so um
valentine's day
sorted that ben barnes is the type of
man i'd let eat spaghettios on my new
bohemian white bed set that's how
absolutely fine this man is slurp slurp
baby it's fine here you've got some
sauce on your chin whip
these are real things that people are
really typed with their real thumbs i'll
eat cereal in bed spaghettios is that's
quite a compliment to let me do that so
thank you ben barnes making everyone
have dirty thoughts every time he posted
the pictures of himself i bet his leo
ass is enjoying this a lot i am a leo so
that's nice that you know that but i i
yes i i enjoy i enjoyed her to comment
underneath the picture as much as the
next man
i would let ben barnes pour hot soup
into my lap then i would apologize to
him
no
i'm british if i poured hot soup into
your lap i would apolo i would be
apologizing profusely to you there's a
thing here with soup and spaghettios and
there's a lot of sort of foodie i'm sure
there's a word for people
right i swear god is my witness i would
give my eternal soul to like
lick a ben barnes's toe just one i would
renege on that deal because toes are not
my best quality i broke one of them
doing a stunt on the punisher and it's
still not quite right feet is not my
thing but um i love that it's your thing
listen i'd never call a man daddy but
for ben barnes i might let out a part
[Laughter]
i have a friend who was called daddy and
he was okay with it and then the next
time she said dad which he was
absolutely not okay with and i totally
get that i don't know where
where i stand on par now i do know where
i stand on it please don't
they're getting i can feel them getting
steadily and there's quite a lot yeah
yeah i would let ben barnes spit in my
mouth and i would use it as mouthwash my
saliva has dried up just reading that
ben barnes could literally snap me in
half and [ __ ] me into the next century
and i would fully let him
well i wouldn't want to do that without
consent so thank you for the consent
whose feet do i need to be to hug ben
barnes and smell him just for once tell
me this is confusing because if i meet
you i'm very willing to hug you so
that's fine you don't need to keep
anyone's beep for that don't give away
more of yourself than you need to the
way i'm not even flexible but i'd let
ben barnes turn me into a pretzel if he
wanted to i love a pretzel a snack then
barnes hold my hand in public and my
neck in private challenge
that is the way round i would do it the
other way around would be somewhat
inappropriate
rust alive
ben barnes i love how everyone's using
my full name ben barnes in case you were
wondering all my holes are free real
estate
bus yo children in my [ __ ] sir bust
your children in my [ __ ] sir
bust your children in my book plus your
children and i don't know how to stress
this um buzzfeed has interjected again
to tell me bus reminds me that bus your
children are
in my bossy sir
ben barnes expand the fold in my bossy
challenge
i'm just going to leave it alone where
it is this is the last one that i'm
going to reveal and i'm
incredibly um worried about some of you
ben barnes
no
you've got parents spend ons let me eat
that ass like a sausage mcgriddle with
extra maple syrup i'd tear that [ __ ] up
i'd say slam on that you feel me your
knees could be the apple pie on the side
i'd munch munch munch that and wash it
down with a cold glass of my tears
oh that took a turn that had everything
that was a bit sexy and then very very
weird and then went back into the whole
food thing we've all got going on then
slump in capital letters just knocked me
back a bit then you called me a [ __ ]
which i wasn't sure how to feel about
apple pie i love and then ending it with
the cold glass of your tears please
don't cry now i might go and have a
little cry now but please don't you cry
thank you everyone for these um
compliments i'm honoured and i will see
you with a can of spaghettios on
february the 14th when i am free
[Music]
you